hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to assessment examination if
you remember the mandela catalog or the
game that was maple county i believe it
was it's an analog horror experiment
this
one is assessing
something
that's probably fine
the examination will now begin
hello friend thanks for applying for
this position at the authenticity
assessment department
all of us here
are very happy to have you if you get
the job that is
today we'll be testing your instincts to
see if you're qualified to perform
authenticity assessments on your own in
a real life scenario okay before that
some quick questions are required to get
some more insight about who we would be
hiring grades please take a sit and
await further instructions
please take a sit well i am seated so
um my name is mark oh how did you hear
about this position
[Music]
uh
i don't really read newspapers no one
told me about it
and i think i found it on the internet
so the internet is just one big fever
dream we're all sharing anyway so i'm
going to say a dream
do you have any professional experience
in this area in what area the aad didn't
exactly tell me what it was it was just
which i don't exactly know what that
means
do you have any profound
i'm gonna say
i played a lot of horror games and i did
a video analyzing analog horror so i
think i do
thank you you're welcome you have any
personal experience in this area
personal experience
in terms of assessing whether someone is
an alternate is that what you're asking
i'm gonna go yes
i'm gonna go no i'm yeah no yeah no yeah
no
oh yes
[Music]
do you fear death
no actually
this feels like the test you know the
quiz about my
would you fear god
no
do you have people you love in your life
i'm gonna go yes and i question anybody
that
well i guess i don't question anybody
that says no
uh
i'm gonna go yes
why do i feel uncomfortable about this
question i don't know
do you fear losing them
sure
eight e2 a one four everybody remember
that eight e two a one four eight
expectations two apples
one
fortnight eighty two a one four eight e
two a one four
i can't even click on that eight e2 a
one four remember that eight e two a one
four eight two a one four
eighty two in a moment we will provide
you with several images of people and
you must determine whether or not these
people are authentic and to be trusted
or threats you should stay away from
please be careful with your selections
our decision on whether to hire you will
depend heavily on your results okay are
you saying all break dancers or
alternates
hi
to trust threat uh well you know the
eyes are a little odd but you know this
guy he's got a nice smile
i'm gonna say
guys totally trustworthy 100 trust me
trust me with my life
grandma
grandma
oh
how could you not trust grandma
[Music]
i mean
seems normal
trust
i got nothing
well okay this guy's just got
scars or something going on with his
face this guy's perfectly normal hey
perfectly trustworthy gentlemen
oh hey
what is what am i why boy who did this
is lovely i'll put it on my fridge thank
you very much what am
i there's a stinky baby over here um
who are you tall
that tree looks suspicious
okay
[Music]
perfectly trustworthy
[Music]
i've never seen anybody more trustworthy
in my life
wow this guy actually does look normal
so
trust
that's fine
you know i'm not gonna question anybody
that has scars or has been in some kind
of an accident lost
their eyes
i'd trust them even more and maybe lost
their
mouth to i
trust
die as a pam take three tablets
[Music]
okay
abraham wallace
this date
very suspicious
hi
oh you look friendly trust
i'm just a trustworthy guy
trust
[Music]
seems fine trust
what a lovely smile trust
oh francisco estrada 19 victim 2 police
department what's your emergency
ah nothing actually i'm fine yeah hi i'm
at dorae park at a gas station actually
in a corner of dorae park i think
there's somebody here who needs help
there's a kid outside he's got some
blood on him
is he hurt
i don't know he looks fine it's just
he's outside and the door's locked so i
can't tell
okay he's asking for help though so i
don't know if you can hear but he's
asking me to help him
okay i'm dispatching an ambulance right
now is there any way you can unlock this
door
oh i can unlock it for sure i work here
i have the keys
then what's stopping you
well i mean i wanted to help him
obviously the moment he came in is a kid
with blood on him for christ's sake but
uh and it's gonna sound like crazy to
you just as i was pulling out my keys i
saw it his
face his face you know he had this look
it reminded me of something i don't know
what something i'm terrified of
[ __ ] i don't know man but something's
off about that kid like real off
you're gonna let this kid bleed out
because he feels off
no that's not what i'm saying he's he's
not dying i don't think he just didn't
look right it's all kid looked like he
just died himself but he hasn't
obviously he looked
like a ghost or a demon it's hard to
explain maybe i'm just [ __ ] up right
now i've been drinking a little bit but
you have to see him scary [ __ ] officer
hmm
officer
he must be pale because of the blood
what did what what what happened what
what why why why would pork you can't
even keep his eyes straight not because
he drank one too many cheap
beers
is he still there how does he look
uh yeah he's i don't know i'm like
crouching under the counter so i can't
even see what he's doing it's [ __ ]
creepy
okay well the ambulance is still a good
20 minutes away and that kid cannot be
doing well so i need you to go assist
him oh [ __ ] that no [ __ ] way no you
didn't see that little [ __ ] he's not
normal
you know refusal to cooperate is a crime
right son
is is that what that is
of course
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay i'll go check on him then
thank you i'll stay on the line
all right
i think maria's antizima
aha
you know
if this is the kid
never seen more trust with a child in my
life
some injury gotta help that young la lad
oh well this by comparison the most
trustworthy thing i've ever seen
person i've ever seen
okay now this little [ __ ]
something right about this but i'm not
trust
hi
how are you okay bye excellent
you have now completed the authenticity
assessment examination i did
congratulations thank you if you are
accepted into
you will receive a letter
that's probably fine
that's probably fine
nothing weird about that
all good here eight e a two a
one
four eighty two a one four i remember
missing
johnsy hassan
uh okay
uh
oh mitchell kramer uh okay
uh wayne green okay
all right
it's a little odd
f e oh am i supposed to
remember
hey
[Music]
i'm just like i got delayed nice shifts
so i'm just
i'm just fasting until i am yeah
i think i'm gonna
really
grab a couple of six
storage
maybe a lot of join
oh no no he'll get pissed off about it
all right
but like
i was gonna do fire me i already put in
my two weeks notice
yeah yeah you know i i told you but
last week
yeah it was for real i was real i'm i'm
just i'm done with this blaze honestly
i barely got any sleep as it is and you
know you had the [ __ ] late night
shift it takes a [ __ ] dollar on me
yeah plus joe's a [ __ ] asshole's ass
yeah super hurts on stone
uh nah
nah not really no i
i think i'm i'm just gonna look around
at you and see what i can find
any place better than just [ __ ] gas
station yeah and i i know
what you mean yeah yeah you know i'll be
free for a couple of weeks
you know oh [ __ ] yeah i know i forgot
about that yeah that's just friday
but yeah i
know putting my guard down i'll be there
i'm letting my guard down oh [ __ ] don't
don't deal with an acid though oh you
know let's make it up with fries and see
what she says
all right
okay cool now my car is going back up my
car's going back up all right
it was too late already why
why was it too late excellent
you have now completed the authenticity
assessment examination
congratulations thank you if you are
accepted
you will receive a letter on april the
23rd at 10 04 a.m
if the letter arrives before that stay
inside lock your doors and windows and
wait for the real letter to arrive
do not call the police
if the real letter does not arrive and
you believe in a god pray to them if
they are real hope they will take pity
on your soul if everything goes well
however we'll see you very soon
we'll be thrilled to have you join our
ever-growing family
you have reached the end of your
examination
uh thank you
okay
oh ah um
there was no real conclusion to that
maybe because i did so poorly on the
test um there's apparently multiple
endings to this
i might have gotten the really
stupid ending
so let's try this again and this time
i'm not going to trust
anybody
i trust nobody the examination will now
begin uh-huh okay
hello friend yes yes yes please be
careful with your selections our
decision on whether to hire you will
depend heavily on your results
okay
i'm gonna go ahead
no
i'm gonna go uh threat 100 threat no
grandma there's no mercy for you this is
a threat
lady sorry threat
sir
you scare me threat
threat
oh my god a threat
threat
threat something is probably something
to do with that e8 a2 no
8e2a14
threat big threat huge threat
a
big threat massive threat okay i i know
about this one
threat hey kids sorry you go bleed
outside i don't want it on my carpets
okay threat
all right kid uh you go join your friend
threat
hey
threat
no
oh it's upside down wait
that's different excellent
you have now completed the authenticity
assessment examination congratulations
okay if you are accepted into
you will receive a letter on
i'll receive a letter on mark i i hear
you loud and clear
and while you're out here why not come
over to dory park
admire the tall and beautiful trees all
around or watch as some of our little
ones grow
bring the kids along they'll have a
fantastic time in our new play area
there is truly no better place to make
beautiful memories jorah park one of the
county's most lovely locations
oh no
i can see his pain i see it from my
window see it every night
okay
how
i can hear his steps
i hear them from my window hear them
every night this is my least favorite
poem
father of many
his tears taste of sacrifice his steps
carry
guilt why haunt this one park why
torment my dreams nightly does he fear
nightmares
i can see his pain
i see it from my window
i can see it's fake
i won't sleep tonight
won't listen to the man's steps or i
will be next
well i didn't rhyme
you have now completed the authenticity
assessment examination congratulations
if you are accepted into
you will receive a letter on april the
23rd at 10 04 am
if the letter arrives before that stay
inside
your doors
and wait for the real letter to arrive
uh-huh okay oh cool all right so that
that i did the all true and the all
false so now i'm gonna go back into it
and i'm gonna try to pick the right
answers and i'll know
if i got the right answer because the
ending will be different i think
[Music]
whoa that's different i was just trying
different answers here evgb f m a f k v
fc every very good boy
feels
much anger for
kind
very
funny children every very good boy feels
much anger for kind
very funny children every very good boy
feels much anger
for kind very funny children
every very good boy every very good boy
fears much oh every very good boy feels
much anger for kind very funny children
every very good boy every very good boy
feels much anger for kind very funny
children
every very good boy feels much anger for
kind very funny
depend heavily on your results
okay i'm gonna be
real particular about this clearly some
uh goop in the eyes that's a threat
100
grandma
your squirrel face ain't right threat
okay lady there's some kind of like
thing going on
eyes are a little
different from each other kind of either
off angle or because this one's going to
i think this is a threat 100 threat
[Music]
this guy just looks scary i don't think
he's a threat though
oh
wait the sound oh unless it's like trust
threat they just make different sounds
they might i have no idea
maybe the high pitched noise is
correct
ah i think i got one wrong then
damn that was probably fine
yeah it goes d i got a dorm
i must have got it wrong
but let's see i might have to go back
around again
what
you kidding me
oh okay so
threat trust and this
yeah i must have gotten wrong
there must have been something really
odd in there that i didn't see oh no i
gotta skip let me just go ahead and
assume that i got that wrong let me go
back it'd be quicker every very good boy
feels much anger for kind very funny
children
wish i remembered what the hell i made
choices on i said this guy was a threat
and that was right ding
grandma's clearly a threat
threat
this person apparently
ding okay that's what it was
this was fine because he was just a dude
dang okay this was a threat
ding yeah
this was clearly threat ding
this one was trust and i think that's
fine
ding yeah
oh my wonder
okay this is where i got it wrong twice
in a row after this i got it wrong twice
in a row after this
because i said this guy was trust but
apparently not
apparently not
and i said
she was trust
but apparently not
unless no
threat
ah
god damn it
uh let's just go again let's just make
sure i just want to make sure i just
want to make sure this is threat i don't
know why is it is it that the i don't
know threat okay next one this is trust
totally fine
this is threat
yeah okay we got it we got it we got it
threat okay cool so with the the kid
i think the first two are obviously
threatened the last one's fine so i just
got to get through that if i screw that
up i'm gonna be very mad
and also if i'm just wrong about the
noises being right and wrong answers we
shall see we shall see but i think i got
it all right
clearly threat
threat
this also
threat
so this is
trust right
come on
no
no
you have now completed the authenticity
examination let's see if it's
why maybe because it was clearly the
same kid morphing
my god
every very good boy
feels much anger for
kind very funny children
now it's the same
it is frustrating this is frustrating
threat
there we go
oh upside downy face
excellent
you have now completed the authenticity
assessment examination
[Applause]
come on give me something good
every very good boy feels much
anger for kind very funny children
are you stunned that that worked as i am
wait
but it was upside down face
but this is
isn't this
but this is the same
isn't it
is there something different in this
because it was an upside downy face hi
um there was nothing different and i'm
saving you time
by not showing you
the exact same thing
okay goodbye
it's the same all right
i don't know how to get this
last perfect ending maybe it has to do
with questions in the personality quiz
as well and those letters and numbers
there's got to be some deeper puzzle but
i have to leave it to you guys i put a
link in the description
for this game that you can try it out
for yourself let me know in the comments
if you find it you know post a video or
whatever because i am curious
what do the letters mean what about
every very good boy feels much anger for
kind very funny children
what's the deal there's got to be
something else
because i got all the questions right
the sound said that it must be in those
numbers in the personality quiz
something about that but
i'll leave that to you
thank you
and as always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
you